do you think there's something totally
new to be invented in jiu-jitsu still
not totally new but
like the you know flying isn't new uh
but airplanes nevertheless made that
much more efficient is there like new
ideas
to be discovered in digital still i'd
say the reason i'd say yes is the same
reason i would say i believe in alchemy
even though i
don't i'm serious like i've got some
backing for this okay um
you know i guess i talk about this with
a buddy of mine a lot like uh
and facilitative versus not facilitative
beliefs
and if i don't believe something is
possible
and i do no investigation towards it
i'll never find something even if it's
there
it's almost like it's no different than
me walking up on a group of people and
going like oh man look at these jerks
this is going to suck
versus me going i wonder what these guys
are up to i'm about to have two very
different conversations even though the
players in the game are no different my
internal constitution has changed
because
of of how i've decided to approach the
situation so although i wouldn't
personally want to spend all my time
trying to turn lead into gold because i
don't believe that it's likely to work
only a person who's willing to spend his
or her life in that pursuit will
actually get to the bottom of that and
also in the in the pursuit of that
they're likely to find
other things so i think a lot of times
the idea is that humanity is pushed
forward by
you know again it's another orson scott
carbon it's like you know human beings
are in this slog it's
paraphrasing just in this slog over time
and then periodically
the humanity gives birth to genius like
someone that invents the wheel invents
electricity pushes us forward
you know comes up with the idea of
governance that doesn't you know just
start and end with the point of a sword
you know and uh
you know these aren't common things
these are unbelievable advancements that
you know that
me sitting here i didn't come up with
them but i just get the benefit of it so
i guess what i would say is a lot of
times these ideas are called crazy you
know
like as we discussed on kind offline
it's like you know einstein was
brilliant in his 20s and it was
brilliant before that i would suspect
but basically uh you know gets
recognized later on in life and
of course we all thought those were
great ideas the man was probably roundly
mocked for
giant chunks of his life and i i guess
so
it's neat to i would say there's
definitely in my mind things that
even if it's just combinations and new
to me new ways to see things new ways to
understand
different depth of understanding
possibly new things new positions new
ideas
because even if that's not true
the process of of going through and
acting as if it is and believing like
that and focusing and
trying to investigate will make any of
us will push us all forward
we're sitting there you know obsessing
over the cult of our current knowledge
i think is the biggest the biggest
danger um and the biggest cause of
stagnation that exists anywhere
yeah and it starts with believing the
the impossible which is kind of
interesting
one of the things that's really
inspiring to me is to see people out
there which
which sadly are rare who kind of have
uh a combination of two things one
is they have a worldview that involves
that includes a lot of ideas that are
crazy and
the second part is they're exceptionally
focused and competent in bringing that
whatever the ideas in that world view to
reality so
there's certainly a lot of people with
crazy ideas you know there's a lot of
conspiracy theories they have
way out their beliefs about things but
they're not
doing much to like make the like build
stuff
grounded like they're not engineers or
whatever they're just like espousing
different crazy ideas but
that's why you get like the elon musk
type characters and the reason i bring
him up a lot is because like there's not
many others to bring up
it's like there's not many examples of
it through history the people
i mean the guy's convinced that we're
going to colonize mars
and basically
everybody on earth thinks that's insane
everyone accept the guy that's going to
do it except that's going to do it and
like
you can imagine like a couple hundred
years from now
people will i mean
first of all they they won't certainly
won't remember the haters
they won't remember all the people if if
they do remember them
they'll remember them in a sense like
people were silly to think that
this isn't the obvious path forward like
from a perspective that's what that's
what elon
talks about like it's obvious that we're
going to expand throughout the universe
like so from his perspective from his
perspective like
but to me it is also obvious because
like either we destroy
ourselves or or will expand beyond earth
like uh like there's not many
you know we well it's not maybe it's not
completely obvious i'm i guess i share
that world view
there's the other possibility that we
humans find
a sort of of an inner peace where the
forces of capitalism will calm down
and we'll all just meditate and do yoga
and jiu jitsu and like relax with this
whole tech thing
where we keep building new technologies
but it's cool to have those kinds of
people
that just believe the big ambitious
crazy dreams
because that's where it starts if you
want to build something spouse you have
to first believe
that when you also have to believe
strongly enough that you're not
vulnerable and i'm speculating but it's
like i can only imagine how many people
have told
elon that what he's doing is crazy so
not only did he dream it up he dreamed
it up went with it and also went with it
in the face of being
told that it's not going to work and
then any time and then also
stepped away from the bitterness because
he's done a series of really crazy
impressive things
and that's only those little things i'm
aware of but and also staying away from
the bitterness of
every single time you did something good
initially i all i do is
talk down about you and then eventually
i act as of course of course i never
apologize
yeah and yet you don't let that dampen
your spirits for the next innovation
which is pretty incredible to me to
watch
yeah it's kind of cool i mean uh it's
contagious to spend time
with the guy because he's not it's rogan
has the same look to him which is
interesting about these people
is uh like
there there's like a hater shield
that he's like he doesn't even like
sense them it feels like
like it doesn't he does he thinks to uh
to elon it's like it's obvious
i mean he keeps calling it like first
principles thinking
like physics says it's true therefore
it's true like he's convinced himself
that like
his beliefs are grounded in the
fundamental fabric of the way the
universe works
therefore the haters don't matter right
and i mean that's kind of like a system
of thought he developed himself
through all the difficulty through all
the doubt he's able to take huge risks
with
basically putting everything he owes on
the line multiple times throughout his
life
amidst all the drama i missed all the
doubts amidst all like the
he's still able to make just clear
clear-headed decisions
it's i i don't know what to make of it
but it's inspiring as hell well
it's i think it's something that's funny
i think like i can only imagine that
you know history will look back on him
as a brilliant person but that's not the
only this there's a lot of maybe not
numeric not statistically speaking but a
lot numerically on a giant planet of you
know billions of people a lot of
brilliant people
well you know time place luck fortune
and all that other stuff but at the same
time
that clearly isn't the only determining
thing in making elon musk elon musk and
obviously i don't know the guy from adam
and
but it's an interesting thing that it's
not just his intellect his belief system
his structure how he's viewing the world
like that's
did he reason his way to that did he not
what other factors came in i'm really
curious about that because i guess
coming
it's again i feel really strongly about
people's belief structure and and this
the how they view the world
being more important than the engine
behind it you know
it makes someone resilient or not it
makes someone positive or not because
you could have ten thousand i think
about this for competitive stuff
you could have ten thousand things going
properly and one thing going in properly
if you focus on the improper you'll
probably fix it at a certain point which
is good
facilitated for development in the long
term but if you had to go and try to
perform a task in the next five minutes
and you're focusing on the negative your
confidence and your your your belief in
in the positive outcome of the future is
likely to be damaged
whereas you could have 25 things going
wrong but you go man i sure am happy to
be alive how fortunate i am this is
great i can't this is i have problems to
solve this is awesome
versus i list the problems and i start
fishing about them
both of them are technically accurate
but it's i guess different lenses and i
think that's a really neat thing to see
you know someone you know exemplifying
that for us
you